ce que claude tu veux que je fasse
l'alphabet pour aller plus vite alors
qu'on sonne première partie baissé à vos
strophes non pas h aux oeufs que moussa
chez moi il n'y a que mon cerveau qui
marche est vraiment et je dois le
nourrir avec les connaissances
[Musique]
lele mora 6 à faire face la chronique
d'erwan le nord publié le 1er mars 2020
dans l'opinion
slc un peu le cerveau et je suis en fait
sa voix donc elle va me transmettre ses
pensées et moi je vais les les rendre
audibles
en fait pour l'autre c'est ça qui est
magique ça a un côté magique
[Musique]
j'ai ressenti cette absence de
financement comme une négation de mon
handicap et de ma volonté en tant que
personnes en situation de handicap à
vouloir faire des études supérieures et
faire partie de la société
pourquoi m'avoir permis d'avoir des avs
jusqu'à mon bac et puis plus rien
comme si mon handicap s'était envolé
avec ma mention très bien au bac mais
bizarrement ce n'est pas le cas j'avais
besoin d'une auxiliaire de vie scolaire
en terminale j'en ai également besoin à
l'université
[Musique]
e
je suis extrêmement fier de chloé et
nous épate tout le temps depuis tout
petit en fait voilà si on m'avait dit
que chloé voilà oreilles son bac qu'elle
l'aurait avec mention très bien
qu'ensuite elle frais sciences po
voilà alors non on sait pas où elle va
aller à chaque fois on se dit non ça va
pas être possible et puis finalement
c'est elle qui va de l'avant et nous on
est là pour l'accompagner mais c'est
vraiment des décisions de chloé j'ai
plus passer mon temps à lui dire
attention c'est pas grave on s'en fout
de la mention fait attention à ton corps
parce que physiquement c'est très
éprouvant
les études pour chloé mais elle écoute
pas souvent sa maman et donc moi je
n'étais plus haut à dire arrête de
bosser un petit peu là prend d'antan
mais voilà c'est son caractère